In this next step, we're going to be adding a shader preview ball, the SM shader sphere,
to our scene and apply various materials to the scene.
Now, an important thing to note here is that we are using materials from the automotive
collection which have been fully calibrated against their real world counterparts.
Loosely translated, these are very high quality materials that we can compare our lighting
against to make sure that we're staying as physically accurate as possible with our scene.
So to do this, I'm going to jump back to our project.
Now inside of our collections, we have calibration.
You see we have the SM shader ball.
Now I'm going to move around my scene real quick, still saying in unlit mode, and I'll
just drag the shader ball into our scene.
And then I can duplicate it a host of ways, Ctrl C, Ctrl V, right click, duplicate, or
I can just hold down the Alt key and drag to whatever direction that I want to and just
get myself a few variations of this shader ball.
Now this shader ball does exist inside of the engine.
In fact, it's shipped with the engine for quite a while.
You can highlight over it and you can see where it's located.
But in this case, again, if we use our collections, it's just handy and preset there.
The other thing that I can do is I can actually go down to various materials.
So inside of our classroom, I've got things like car paint and then a couple of ways that
we can add this simply drag and drop it onto the shader preview ball.
Or if we reset that, we can actually just select our material, drag and drop into our
element zero or with a selected hit our little arrow.
Either way, very quick way to do this.
Now for the purposes of our class, I'm just going to add a few materials that I do want
to compare against.
Ideally, giving myself a broad range of things to compare against.
So for example, I may take our glass or add this on there.
I may go down into some various metals like chrome or our iron.
Now if you do want to pursue other materials that are in here, we've got the automotive
materials folder and inside of this, you'll see that we have various different materials
based off of interior and exterior to compare against.
The point here is that we really just want to have a good range of different materials
to compare our lighting against.
So I may go in and add, actually you know what, let's look for some leather.
So in here and maybe I'll just find something like this orange, drag this on there as well.
And then again, just make sure that you have at least a good, we'll use this floor mats
as well, why not?
We'll have a good variation of materials that we can compare against.
Now if I do go to lit mode, you'll see again, we don't have any lighting, so these will
continue to stay in the shadows for lack of better terms.